gratuit et facilement accessible parking
extérieur face à l'Heure Tranquille à
Tours va pourtant recevoir amputer de
200 places si on a décidé son
propriétaire la société d'équipement de
Touraine qui veut tient planter un
projet immobilier avec des conséquences
notamment pour les clients du cinéma CGR
Ellen chapelet
la semaine les deux
positionnement qui se situaient devant
le cinéma tout rangeau du quartier des
deux lions sont en cours de destruction
elles vont être remplacées par un espace
ludique temporaire avec des équipements
de sport en plein air 6000 m² en moins
pour se garer une déconvenue pour les
cinéphiles rencontrés ce mercredi matin
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
fermeture des 200 places de parking qui
sont derrière vous bah encore une galère
pour se garer voilà on peut pas se garer
n'importe où au bowling on n'a pas le
droit bon maintenant le McDo ils ont
fait avec le CGR on peut se garer mais
même pour les restaurants et tout c'est
pas du tout pratique pratique créer de
nouveaux espaces c'est aussi plutôt pas
mal mais effectivement si ça complique
quelque chose pour se garer ça va pas
arranger tous ceux qui viennent en
voiture ça va forcément ramener beaucoup
de monde dans le parking souterrain donc
est-ce qu'il y en aura suffisamment une
heure et demie gratuite est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour aller au cinéma
aujourd'hui tous les usagers du parking
souterrain du centre commercial de
l'Heure Tranquille ont en effet droit à
une heure et demie de stationnement
gratuit mais effectivement ce n'est pas
suffisant quand on va au cinéma des
négociations sont d'ailleurs en cours
entre la direction du CGR et le
gestionnaire de ce parking pour y
remédier
on travaille sur deux axes principaux
qui sont dans un premier temps de de
d'offrir une heure de stationnement
supplémentaire ou une heure trente déjà
gratuite dans le parking souterrain du
centre commercial leur tranquille et le
second axe c'est de réserver les places
de stationnement qui nous appartiennent
sur la partie côté McDo de réserver ses
places là au client du restaurant
McDonald's et du cinéma CGR en attendant
il faudra payer le parking souterrain ou
arriver encore plus tôt avant la séance
car ce mercredi matin dès 11h elle les
places restantes sur le parking en plein
air se comptait déjà sur les doigts
d'une main